I was going to say I want a top line of
what makes a horrible date you already
gotten an argument we got in an argument
because he was like I don't want my wife
to work and I want two kids but he
already had one kid and I was like well
why do I have to have two if you already
have one and he was like because I want
two by my wife and I said that is the
most selfish thing you have too and then
the argument started because he said you
couldn't if you're married you couldn't
spend more than 500 on a gift right for
the other for the other person without
permission and I said well why do I need
permission what if I what if your
husband's been talking about a watch and
you want to surprise them whatever or
like a shirt I don't know and it's more
than whatever and he said well that's
money that could be going towards the
children which in theory is nice but I
said but I wasn't supposed to be working
anyway right so you weren't even
counting on my money your money should
be going towards the kids and then he
wanted one joint bank account and I said
but then
this is all on a first date